I met 273 startup founders last year and
each one was looking for money as a tech
investor my goal was to sort through
everyone that I met and make a quick
determination about which ones had the
potential to make something really big
but what makes a great founder this is a
question I asked myself daily some
venture capitalists placed bets based on
a founders previous background did they
go to an Ivy League school have they
worked at a blue chip company have they
built out a big vision before
effectively how smart is this person
other VCS assess the founders emotional
quotient or EQ how well will this person
build teams and build rapport across
customers and clients I have a different
methodology to assess startup founders
though and it's not complicated I look
for signs of one specific trait not IQ
not EQ its adaptability how well a
person reacts to the inevitability of
change and lots of it that's the single
most important determinant for me I
subscribe to the belief the adaptability
itself is a form of intelligence and our
adaptability quotient or aq is something
that can be measured tested and improved
aq isn't just useful for startup
founders however I think it's
increasingly important for all of us
because the world is speeding up we know
that the rate of technological change is
accelerating which is forcing our brains
to react whether you're navigating
changing job conditions brought on by
automation shifting geopolitics in a
more globalized world or simply changing
family dynamics and personal
relationships each of us as individuals
groups corporations and even governments
are being forced to grapple with more
change than ever before in human history
so how do we assess our adaptability I
use three tricks when meeting with
founders here's the first think back to
your most recent job interview what kind
of questions were you asked
probably some variation of tell me about
a time when right instead to interview
for adaptability I like to ask what is
questions what if your main revenue
stream were to dry up overnight what if
a heat wave prevented every single
customer from being able to visit your
store asking what if instead of asking
about the past forces the brain to
simulate to picture multiple possible
versions of the future the strength of
that vision as well as how many distinct
scenarios someone can conjure tells me a
lot practicing simulations is a sort of
safe testing ground for improving
adaptability instead of testing how you
take in and retain information like an
IQ test might it tests how you
manipulate information given a
constraint in order to achieve a
specific goal the second trick that I
use to assess adaptability and founders
is to look for signs of unlearning
active on learners seek to challenge
what they presume to already know and
instead override that data with new
information kind of like a computer
running a disk clean up take the example
of Destin Sandlin who programmed his
bicycle to turn left when you start it
right and vice-versa
he called this his backwards brain bike
and it took him in nearly eight months
just to learn how to ride it kinda sorta
normally the fact that Dustin was able
to unlearn his regular bike in favor of
a new one though signals something
awesome about our adaptability it's not
fixed instead each of us had the
capacity to improve it through
dedication and hard work on the last
page of Gandhi's autobiography he wrote
I must reduce myself to zero at many
points in his very full life he was
still seeking to return to a beginner's
mind set to zero to unlearn in this way
I think it's pretty safe to say Gandhi
had a high aq score the third and final
trick that I use to assess the founders
adaptability
is to look for people who infuse
exploration into their life and their
business there's a sort of natural
tension between exploration and
exploitation
and collectively all of us tend to
overvalue exploitation here's what I
mean in the year 2000 a man finagled his
way into a meeting with John antio
co-ceo Blockbuster and proposed a
partnership to manage blockbusters
fledgling online business the CEO John
laughed him out of the room saying I
have millions of existing customers and
thousands of successful retail stores I
really need to focus on the money the
other man in the meeting however turned
out to be Reed Hastings the CEO of
Netflix in 2018 Netflix brought in
fifteen point eight billion dollars
while blockbuster file for bankruptcy in
2010 directly ten years after that
meeting the blockbuster CEO was too
focused on exploiting his already
successful business model so much so
that he couldn't see around the next
corner and that way his previous success
became the enemy of his adaptability
potential for the founders that I work
with a frame exploration as a state of
constant seeking to never fell too far
in love with your wins but rather
continue to proactively seek out what
might kill you next when I first started
exploring adaptability the thing I found
most exciting is that we can improve it
each of us has the capacity to become
more adaptable but think of it like a
muscle it's got to be exercised and
don't get discouraged if it takes a
while remember Destin Sandlin it took
him eight months just to learn how to
ride a bike over time using the tricks
that I use on founders asking what if
questions actively unlearning
and prioritizing exploration ever
over-exploitation can put you in the
driver's seat so that the next time
something big changes you're already
prepared we're entering a future or IQ
and EQ both matter way less than how
fast you're able to adapt so I hope
these tools help you to raise your own
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]